Speaker 1: I hope everybody had a good Memorial
Day weekend.
If you live in the United States and you had
a day off on Monday.
You know, I received many emails over the
weekend about the debt ceiling and the bill
that may have been reached to avoid defaulting
on U.S. debt.
And many of you were saying, David, why haven't
you been covering this?
Why aren't you covering this?
And it is true, other than I believe it was
just one story on the world famous award winning
bonus show.
I have not spoken about the debt ceiling debate,
controversy, whatever you want to call it.
And that has not been by accident.
It's been on purpose.
And I want to explain to you why and then
I want to hear from you.
Does this make sense or should I have been
talking about it all along?
Now, as a reminder, the debt ceiling is the
legal limit on how much the federal government
can borrow to pay its bills.
And importantly, it has nothing to do with
new spending.
When we talk about the debt ceiling, we're
talking about borrowing to honor prior obligations
already approved by Congress.
So when people want to debate, well, we should
allow the U.S. to default because I'm against
the Inflation Reduction Act or whatever the
case may be.
This is not about debating new spending.
This is about meeting obligations for already
approved spending.
And there are four reasons that I have made
the deliberate choice.
And they all have to do with respect for you
in the audience for reasons why I haven't
been covering this.
Now, first of all.
The same thing happens every time.
And this alone isn't a reason not to talk
about something.
Things in politics will happen more than once,
or at least they'll have been almost identically
more than once.
But every time the debt ceiling is reached,
and that happens regularly because the government
runs a deficit, you see Republicans threatening
to block its increase unless they get concessions
from Democrats.
They talk about writing checks we can't cash.
They talk about spending cuts.
They talk about policy issues, and it creates
drama and uncertainty.
But it is mostly a political stunt.
And I'm being clear here from the point of
view of Republicans talking about defaulting,
Republicans know that the U.S. can't actually
be allowed to default on its debt because
it would be catastrophic to both the American
economy and to the reputation of Republicans.
Now, if they could get away with it, with
somehow Democrats getting blamed, maybe they
would go for it.
But they also know it would be bad for many
of their constituents to allow the U.S. to
default and that they would get at least some
of the blame, if not.
Also, they eventually cave and they agree
to raise the debt ceiling.
Sometimes it's at the last minute after a
temporary extension.
It's the same routine time and again.
So it's happened many, many times and it is
happening now.
Secondly, it's all bad for the American people.
And what I mean by that is not the defaulting
that might happen, which would, of course,
be bad.
But the debt ceiling debate is bad for the
American people as a narrative and a storyline.
It's not only pointless, it's also harmful.
It waste time and resources that could be
spent on actual important issues like new
infrastructure programs or getting people
health care.
Climate change.
It undermines the credibility and the stability
of the United States.
As a borrower and a leader in the world.
The more we publicize this absurd, antiquated,
retrograde system, which gets us to these
debt ceiling debates in the first place, the
dumber we look on the global stage, it's unnecessary.
It creates volatility and risk in the financial
markets.
That hurts everybody, even people not in the
markets, just straight up consumers.
It increases the cost of borrowing for the
government.
That adds to the debt burden even more in
the long run.
And according to some estimates, the debt
ceiling crises of 2011 and 2013 actually pushed
interest rates up somewhere between half a
point and two points, costing taxpayers billions
of dollars.
So I don't want to participate in worsening
that situation.
Number three, they eventually come to an agreement,
despite the theatrics and the grandstanding
and the brinkmanship and the entire thing.
Both parties know sooner or later you're going
to have to raise the debt ceiling.
And what they try to get in the meantime is
screen time, which I'll get to, or concessions
which may or may not actually make any sense.
They can't afford to let the U.S. default
on its obligations, which could trigger a
financial meltdown, a potential recession.
They also don't want to face backlash from
voters at the end of the day and from businesses
who would suffer in such a scenario.
So they strike a deal that involves some minor
concessions or compromises.
The concessions or compromises aren't significant
enough to say.
That's why it was good that they were holding
out.
And it fundamentally changes nothing about
the fiscal situation or the underlying situation
in which we find ourselves.
And lastly, it's an attempt for politicians
to cynically get attention during negotiations.
Look at how many stories there were about
McCarthy's heading to the White House to meet
with Biden.
And then they're sitting there.
The debt ceiling debate is not actually about
fiscal responsibility the way Republicans
love to claim.
It's not really about economic policy either,
because the policies that get us to this situation
every however many months also aren't being
discussed in any serious way.
It's about posturing and messaging.
Can I get a meeting with the president?
Can I, as a Republican, accused Democrats
of being fiscally irresponsible?
Everybody's trying to score points with the
base and attack their opponents and I guess
get some leverage to maybe get some extra
concessions or advance their agenda somewhere
else.
Some Republicans have been trying to link
the debt ceiling to blocking the infrastructure
plan or reversing some Biden executive orders.
So the reasons that I haven't covered it are
because in order to cover it in the way that
it is mostly being covered, I have to insult
my audience by pretending that there is something
different going on than the exact same thing
that always goes on and it becomes a distraction
from more important, urgent matters that affect
our lives and our future now.
I won't deny if the U.S. did default on its
debt and did not raise the debt ceiling, it
would be now not only globally chaotic, it
would start to affect individuals who are
waiting on certain government payments and
in other situations.
I don't deny that.
But the point is, I don't believe that that's
actually at risk of happening for any significant
period of time, more than a few days.
At the end of the day.
What could I possibly add to the normal debate
about the debt ceiling?
This segment is the real analysis, which is
it's an analysis of the way that the debt
ceiling is discussed, the way that the debt
ceiling debate is portrayed in media and used
cynically by our elected officials.
But there's really nothing for me to add to
that.
This is the real analysis.
Agree or disagree?
I want to hear from you and I haven't been
covering it fundamentally out of respect for
my audience